over 2 billion cups of coffee are
consumed every day and it takes a lot of
people to make just one cup one man went
on a quest to figure out what it's like
to thank each and every one of them AJ
Jacobs is a writer who lives in New York
City hi I'm AJ and he's the first to
admit he can be a bit of a grouch my
default state is grumpiness I am very
good and noticing all the things that go
wrong so to make a change he started
giving thanks during dinner I would say
thank you doing everyone who helped make
my meal until one night my ten year old
son was like you know dad those people
can't hear you if you really cared you
would go and thank these people in
person and that's when the light bulb
went off he decided to hone in on
something he knew he took for granted
every day my morning cup of coffee over
the next 12 months
AJ set out to thank every single person
who had even the smallest role in his
morning cup of joe first it was his
local barista the roaster and the coffee
shop sorcerer whenever I thanked one
person they would say well I couldn't do
my job without this person
so one person led to another led to
another led to another you ventured
outside the city and eventually the
country I thank the folks who provide
electricity to the coffee shop the
engineers who provide the water the
people who make the steel the farmer and
the importer the truck driver
the person who paved the road even the
woman who painted the yellow lines in
the road so that my coffee beans could
safely arrive at my coffee shop I
remember I called the woman who does
pest control for the warehouse and I
said I know this sounds strange but I
want to thank you for keeping the
insects out of my coffee and she said
well that don't sound strange but thank
you you know I don't get a lot of
appreciation in my job all in AJ ended
up thanking over 1,000 different
people and while most were pleasantly
surprised by his gratitude it's AJ who
benefited the most the experience has
made me grateful for the hundreds of
things that go right every day as
opposed to the three or four that go
wrong I tell my friends that they should
try these gratitude trails themselves it
could just be small gestures looking
someone in the eye the cashier at the
drugstore and could be sending a quick
note to the designer of a logo you love
I will tell you that it will make your
life better
it's changed the way I live my life
[Music]